welcome back to a20 in this section and
the following ones we talk about
paradoxes in special relativity
a paradox is something which is absorbed
absurd or self-contradictory
so we have statements which don't really
make any sense when brought
together
um the poll in the barn paradox is
rather interesting and we will analyze
this and at the end of the discussion
we'll hopefully agree that there is no
paradox here the pseudo paradox okay so
the situation is as follows we have
alice she has a pole the pole is 10
meters long in her reference frame
and bob is very proud of his new england
barn which is in his reference frame 8
meters long
alice however is moving with a velocity
of 0.6 times the speed of light which
gives us a gamma factor of 1.25
does the pole fit into the barn is a
question or not
so stop here and think about this for a
second and we will continue with another
analysis of this
so here
is the analysis for analysis frame and
the analysis for bob's frame
for alice the barn in her reference
frame is lawrence contracted
it's 6.4 meters long but her pole is 10
meters long so will she clearly answer
this question by saying
it doesn't fit
in bob's frame the barn is eight meters
long and the pole is low and contracted
also eight meters long
so bob will say yeah it fits it just
barely fits they're exactly the same
size so yes the pole fits into the barn
and here is where you might think
this is
an absolute statement they cannot be
both right
we will see
they can they can both be right they
just disagree on the fact that events
happen simultaneously
what are the crucial events here when
does the barn hits the end as if the
pole hits the end of the barn and when
does the back of the pole hit the front
of the barn those are the two things we
have to
study in detail
but let's get to it
how can they or why can't they disagree
so the idea is that you draw space-time
diagrams
for the pole in the barn
and show that
there's no paradox by using the word
lines of the pole
before we do this we want to analyze
this a little bit more
so
assume that
the front of the pole
enters the barn at time equal zero for
both bob and alice
then bob observes the pole entering the
spawn and it takes 44.4 nanoseconds
eight meters divided by 0.6 times the
speed of light for the front
of the pole to reach the back of the
bond and
the back of the pole to reach the front
of the bond
so after 44 nanoseconds
in bob's reference frame
the pole is in the bomb
alice however
sees the
barn loans contracted it's 6.4 meters
long she moves with 0.6 times the speed
of light
so for her she reaches the back
after 35.6 nanoseconds
in which case
bob's clock only shows 28.4 nanoseconds
because
alice's clock time is launch control
so
we can clearly conclude here that that's
not enough time for bob such that the
the pole actually entered the barn full
his full length so the back of the pole
is still outside
so we want to consider three different
events the first event is
after 44 nanoseconds and at a space of
eight meters in bob's reference frame
for alice this situation we just
analyzed
36.6 35.6 nanoseconds passed
um and in her reference frame the front
of the pole is at zero meters
the second event is then
the other side of the barn in bob's
reference frame after 44.4 nanoseconds
zero meters
he sees
or she sees
that 55 nanoseconds have passed we use
lawrence transformation here
um but the position is minus 10 meters
okay and the last point is
28.4 nanoseconds in zero meters
that is the observation when ali sees
the end of the front of the barn the
front of the pole at the end of the barn
um that translates into
analysis frame of 35.6 nanoseconds
and minus
6.4 meters
so the minus 6.4 meters tell you very
clearly what we just already said the
back of the pole is still outside
okay well that's the
quantitative or numerical kind of
evaluation
um and we can also show the very same
thing in the space-time diagram
so we show the space-time diagram here
and
this is bob's reference frame
the poll just touched the front of this
barn
on the barn is located at eight meters
the end of the barn is located at x
meters the front of the barn is located
at zero meters
after 44 nanoseconds there's event
number one and event number two the port
is fully in the barn
but we can also show the pole on this
event number three
so one
where is the end of the pole
we look at this diagram here
where's the end of the pole
when
the front of the pole hits the end of
the barn
you see clearly there's a piece sticking
out we saw that there's
in this event here
6.6 meters in ls frame still sticking
out
so we see that event number three is
located here
and
not all the all of the poll is actually
contained within the bar
so
bob and alice disagree on whether the
front and the back of the pole are in
the in the bond simultaneously that's
where
the situation becomes uh contradictory
they don't agree that two events which
happened at the same time
in their reference frame
and bob's reference then occur at the
same time in alice's reference
you